thank you all for coming here today I
will now read from my pre-prepared
statement as you all know my original
vision for the sands is Ness episode of
game theory was totally ruined by the
studio that's why for years fans have
been crying out to see that episode and
it's originally conceived grim dark
glory so as a result I've partnered with
HBO who will be giving me 30 million
dollars to turn that pivotal story of
one video game character secretly being
another video game character back into
the original vision that I had for it a
six-part miniseries of course because
the direction of the channels have had
to go in the intervening years none of
it will be canon unless people really
like it then maybe it'll be canon or
have it splinter off into an alternate
canon universe of theories not quite
sure yet no further questions at this
time
hello Internet
welcome to film theory we're upcoming
director's cut will feature all 750 film
and game theory episodes with all the
demonetised bowl cut content added back
in including the 14 minute nude ballet
originally intended for the Thanos
versus ant-man but episode not gonna
want to miss that one it was considered
too hot for YouTube the people who've
seen it though poof they only have this
to say why but despite this landmark
announcement I'm afraid that our
director's cut is being overshadowed by
another director's cut the infamous
Snider cut of Justice League to catch
you up WB's big superhero team-up movie
was met with a big back when it first
hit theaters in 2017 to a certain subset
of fans it didn't make sense I mean this
was the Justice League I mean we're
talking Batman Aquaman flash man
mustache man robot man and girl coming
together this wasn't gonna be a Marvel
rainbow-colored flouncy trounce the
adventure this was gonna be epic grim
dark we live in a society and it's gonna
tell us about it and it wasn't too many
who watched the movie oohs chest
forgettable almost immediately a rumor
began spreading about a wildly different
kind of movie a four-hour version that
it existed when an original director
Zack Snyder was helming the project you
see after a terrible family tragedy
forced Zack off the project Warner
Brothers brought former Avengers
director Joss Whedon on board
retooled Zak's vision into something
more mainstream the result was more
color more comedy and more confusion
because it was a big departure from the
gritty darker tone of the movies that
had come before and so fans started a
massive grassroots movement to quote
release the Snyder cut that original
four-hour edit expressing the original
directors original vision of the film
which may or may not have actually ever
existed adding fuel to the fire was the
fact that in the intervening years a few
people have come out to say that they've
seen this fabled movie and that it was
incredible
fans wouldn't let this you rest and kept
pressure up for years even getting
original Justice League cast members
like Jason Momoa on board but finally
after three years of hashtags billboards
petitions HBO finally finally announced
that Zack Snyder's vision would get a
chance to be seen on their new streaming
service HBO Max next year after 30
million dollars of additional production
get infused in the project to finish it
off whether or not it's a polished
version of that original four hour movie
or more likely a six episode miniseries
is yet to be seen but with this one
announcement a whirlwind of questions
have come up will it be canon to the DC
EU probably not unless it's hits will
actors that have left the universe like
Ben Affleck and Henry Cavill returned to
the series probably not unless it's a
hit will we finally get to see justice
league to the new gods probably not
unless it's a hit you'll notice a theme
here the caveat of it being a hit which
i think is a moot point
loyal film theorists it's my theory
today that the Snyder cut has zero
chance of failing notice that I didn't
say it would be a great movie far from
it I think it'll be a confused gritty
mess at worse and slightly better than
the original and absolute best no it's
my theory today that the Justice League
Snyder cut is too big to fail there are
so many things going for this thing that
it's about as close to a guaranteed slam
dunk winner as you can get so I'm
calling it now the Snyder cut is gonna
be a smash hit and today I'm gonna prove
to you why let's start where this whole
thing started and talk about the fans
clearly there is a large group of
impassioned fans who fought for years to
make this movie happen this
grupe would seem like they'd be the
harshest critics for a movie like this
hardcore fans of the franchise
scrutinizing every last detail to make
sure it's comic correct and that would
be true if it weren't for one teeny tiny
little thing standing in their way
basic human psychology back in 1959 a
researcher named Leon Festinger got test
subjects to do an excruciatingly ly
boring activity turning pegs in a
pegboard for an hour those test subjects
were then paid either $1 or $20 to
basically lie to the next person in line
for the test telling them that this
boring experiment would actually be fun
for them that next person in line by the
way was just another researcher so it
was all part of the experiment anyway
when the original test subjects were
asked to rate the overall fun of that
peg turning the test subjects paid only
$1 rated the experiment as more fun than
those were paid $20 the conclusion that
Festinger reached here was that the test
subjects only earning $1 had basically
convinced themselves that the activity
was more fun in order to justify the
fact that they did it in the first place
whereas those paid $20 had enough
outside reward to be honest about how
lame the activity really was this led to
the theory of cognitive dissonance
actually one of my all-time favorite
psychological phenomenon basically that
human psychology aims to hold our
beliefs and behavior in a state of
consistency when there's a disharmony or
a dissonance like saying something was
fun when you know that it wasn't the
brain corrects itself to lessen that
friction to lessen the dissonance in
this case convincing itself that things
were more fun than they actually were so
the brain shifts its perceptions and
says you know what it was actually more
fun than I thought you know the whole
motto fake it till you make it like
you're tired but you pretend to not be
tired and eventually your body catches
up so that you're no longer feeling
tired well that is cognitive dissonance
in a nutshell your actions say that
you're not tired but your brain thinks
it is creating this dissonance and then
after seeing behavior of not being tired
for long enough the brain adjusts to
correct itself deciding that it wasn't
actually tired after all the reason I
bring all of this up is that Justice
League Snyder cut fans are in this boat
for the last three years they've been
petitioning non-stop on social
Media to make this thing happen
believing that the Snyder cut is gonna
be some magical solution to what was
otherwise a mediocre movie that is a lot
of time and energy and most importantly
emotional investment as such when the
movie or miniseries or whatever comes
out on HBO max even if it's bad their
brains
won't want to process it it'll create
dissonance their behavior for the past
three years has said this thing is gonna
be good and the brain will be forced to
adjust accordingly to fit that behavior
to correct for the dissonance the long
and short of it is that even if the
Snyder cut is bad or mediocre or
whatever their brains won't want to
process the bad this also ties into
another psychological concept belief
perseverance it's probably won't come as
much of a surprise to anyone who's been
online like ever but humans are very
reluctant to change their minds about
things the first study of this was done
by again our good buddy Leon Festinger
in this new study he and his team of
psychologists looked at cult members who
were convinced that the world was gonna
end on December 21st 1954 when it didn't
most believers still clung to their
faith even though it had just been
proven wrong cuz you know planet Earth
was still standing in fact defying all
logic future studies found that
presenting evidence that debunks the
belief may actually cause the incorrect
belief to strengthen something deemed by
psychologists as the backfire effect as
famous physicist Max Planck wrote in
what has got to be one of the most
accurate and depressing quotes of all
time the new scientific truth does not
triumph by convincing its opponents and
making them see right but rather because
its opponents eventually die and a new
generation grows out that is familiar
with it ever wonder why it's so hard to
win an online Twitter argument or get a
family member to remove an offensive
Facebook post or heck why so many people
embroiled in controversy get second
third and fourth chances at life it's
all the effects of belief perseverance
and cognitive dissonance so again we see
how Justice League can't fail in the
eyes of the Snyder cut fandom three
years of being convinced it not only
exists but that it's gonna be great
can't be wrong even if it is objectively
wrong
but let's be honest the deck is
certainly stacked in its favor look at
another part of this equation the
project itself and its director Zack
Snyder you know the saying hindsight is
2020 basically it means that if put in a
do-over situation most people would
learn from their mistakes and do a
slightly better job the second time
around and that's exactly the position
that Zack Snyder is currently in at this
point he's gone to see all the critical
responses to the original Justice League
the good and the bad and no matter what
his original vision for the film was no
matter what he added to that project
versus what joss whedon added to that
project it doesn't matter now he's able
to shape it all into something new
something that responds to a lot of
those criticisms you don't have to look
too far to see how effective this can be
by listening to the fans the Sonic the
Hedgehog movie became the surprise
underdog story of the year
and let's be honest it's currently on
pace to be 2020s Oscar Best Picture
winner considering nothing else is
coming into theaters anytime soon yeah
that was just earlier this year not an
entire decade ago like it feels Sonic's
first trailer was horrific causing the
kind of fan backlash usually reserved
for Star Wars films when we first saw
Sonic he was terrifying tiny eyes weird
fur huge human teeth that made everyone
who saw the original trailer feel like
Tom after the nearly universal negative
reception to the trailer Sony delayed
the movie and spent millions reworking
Sonic into something infinitely better
and the results speak for themselves
with the sonic movie outpacing even its
most optimistic projections to become
the highest-grossing video game movie in
US history historically movie studios
keep customers at arm's length storing
all their film reels and secret vaults
protected by top men to keep spoilers
about Holt's new stretch pants from
leaking as a result by the time the
first trailer for a movie drops it's
usually too late to change anything and
negative reactions can kill the project
before it even hits theaters but by
listening to their audience
Sony engaged their customers just like
we do here on YouTube each and every
week subscribe if you haven't by the way
it'd be really nice to get this channel
to 10 million subscribers by the end of
the year so we can get the time and play
button which would make this miserable
sucky sucky awful awful year suck just a
little bit less for this channel and
it's literally free heck YouTube's
barely shows you subscriptions anyway so
you'd be helping me feel better about
life and costing yourself
literally nothing probably not even your
homepage feed so you could do that that
would be nifty anyway you can see where
I'm going with this right Zack Snyder
not only has feedback from a trailer he
has feedback from a whole movie he has
all the market testing he needs to go
back and remake his original vision into
the best possible piece of cinema that
he can based on what everyone was saying
about the movie whether or not it was
truly his original vision it's actually
kind of brilliant
and speaking of brilliant moves here we
got to talk about HBO infusing another
thirty million dollars into a three year
old movie that already massively
underperformed at the box office seems
like it should be a bad idea right but
Zack Snyder's mystery movie is a
built-in marketing magnet even if you
hated Justice League or didn't even care
about Justice League seeing this new
version that the fans unquestionably
made happen is the kind of event that
people aren't gonna want to miss even if
you haven't been actively involved for
calling for the Snyder cut you've almost
certainly seen the random released the
Snyder cut comments appearing on nearly
every video anyone has posted on YouTube
for the past three years along with the
incredibly popular hashtag released the
Snyder cut the movement alone is gonna
get the Snyder cut a huge amount of
media attention when it finally launches
and it might legitimately draw people
into HBO max if only for the two months
that it runs me maybe I'm just being
cynical here but it doesn't surprise me
that a service that offers a 7-day and
30 day free trial period turns what we
were told was a four hour movie into a
potential six-part miniseries that'll
take more than a month to be fully
released just saying and here's the best
part of all of this it's airing on HBO
max there's no way to know the real
numbers the whole thing could be awful
it could be a complete garbage fire of
creativity that no one watches and even
fewer subscribe to HBO max four and none
of it would matter because the numbers
are hidden unlike theatrical releases
where you can very clearly measure the
success or failure of a project based on
box office earnings literally hours
after a movie is released on private
streaming sites like HBO max Disney Plus
Netflix there's no way to know the real
data
what are these view counts are they in
the millions are they the hundreds of
thousands are they just a thousand or
10,000 you have no clue
because this is a brand new streaming
service and a massive project for that
streaming service I guarantee you HBO
will ensure that this experiment will
appear successful no matter how it
actually turns out so at the very best
you might get numbers of people who
actually watch this thing but at worst
you're still gonna be getting this was
great on the platform we saw huge
amounts of viewership and subscribership
we're thrilled with the reception and
the turnout the Snider cut is our most
watched whatever whatever whatever and
we can't wait to do more with the
director the long and short of it all is
that the Snider cut is just too big to
fail the audience is psychologically
primed to like it the director has all
the tools that he needs to fix any
previous mistakes and the platform
itself that it's airing on can tell us
whatever it wants to about how it
performs because there's no way to
really know it is a guaranteed success
and it wouldn't surprise me if it's the
ship that launches a whole spin-off
universe even if this time no one is
really asking for it but hey that's just
a theory a film theory
and cut